who would you say is more pro-trump
um DeSantis or lake Lake okay is it even
a question no she said the other day my
second my husband is my my second
favorite person
she says because my favorite person is
Trump okay so it's fair to say she's
more pro-trump right than the scientist
right is it fair to say that Lake Trump
and DeSantis all have similar backbones
yes okay they're all tough they're not
lightweights you can't push them around
She's Not Afraid the Santa is not afraid
and obviously Trump Is Not Afraid okay
a a if if you had to choose between
those two as a VP for Trump which one
would you choose
I would choose DeSantis but I can also
see that there is a there could be a
personality weakness that will cause
Trump to pick Lake in other words it's a
personality weakness if somebody is all
about the flattery it's a personality
weakness if someone says I need to pick
the person who thinks I'm the greatest
and if that is Trump's Soul metric and
there are some people who think it is he
will pick like for that reason but what
I'm saying is that if Trump is thinking
in terms of his own best interest and
his own best interest alone then he will
say that look there were things that I
didn't do the last time I've got to be
honest about my own presidency I should
have fired Comey on day one I would have
avoided myself a whole lot of problems
had I done that I should have gotten rid
of Christopher Ray I need an inside
administrative guy who is a massive ass
kicker and and I need someone who has
the experience of doing that and would
have the trust of the Republican base
that they will do that for me who's that
guy
that's going to be DeSantis Carrie lake
is a newcomer she's a newscaster she's
going to be a first term let's just say
she wins she'll be a first term Governor
let her get her experience there's
probably gonna be I mean hey you talk
about 12 years they could be a descent
to scary Lake ticket 12 years from now
so in other words these people have not
in 12 years four years from now six
years from now yeah so I'm just saying
there are options down the road but I
would if I were Trump I would not go
with somebody as new as Kerry now let me
give you the DeSantis argument for the
people that are pro de santis I I fully
understand the uh uh pro-trump argument
I understand the like argument let's
talk about the descentesis argument
the people who are in his ear okay
there's a difference between who gives
me advice versus what I know what's
going on meaning people can tell me pal
let me tell you here's who you are
you're so this you're so dumb like we're
not there yet we're three years away but
I appreciate the compliment but we're
not there yet right
who do you what do you think people
around the centers are telling them you
think they're telling them I think if
Trump calls you as a VP you take it I
think you start negotiating right now
with Trump for you to be the VP or do
you think people on this Camp are saying
everybody in America is modeling after
your state the chances of having this
opportunity again may not happen for a
long time because we're gonna forget
about covet in six years because 2024
you got 2028 ain't nobody talking covet
in 2028 they're gonna be like dude kovid
was 10 years ago because in 27 2028 it's
going to be what seven eight years ago
right people are over it they've moved
on by that time so if he runs on his
record of covet in 2027 2028 nothing's
going to happen there right and then if
he you know and then you know if he sits
and waits and then he runs on the uh you
know the uh his record as a governor
under Trump they're going to say well
because Trump was a president it wasn't
really you it's because Trump trump was
really the president this is your time
to run you out around so as much as you
know many Republicans I'm sure think a
trump DeSantis ticket is game over yes I
also don't know the council that's being
given to the centers behind closed doors
is hey you you should be open to the
number two idea rather than the number
one idea I don't know if I see that
good point I don't know what the
DeSantis team is telling him uh I do
know DeSantis
um and um DeSantis interestingly when um
when DeSantis was in Congress
DeSantis was a guy who helped me during
my case with the with the um with the
Obama people because in Congress you can
get access to information remember the
Republicans control the Congress and so
they got a hold the Congressional
committee got a hold of my FBI file and
they say hey Dinesh DeSantis tells me he
says inside your FBI file even before
your case began they flag you as like a
right winger and what he's getting at is
that look if you're pursuing a campaign
Finance case you're not supposed to be
looking at the politics of the guy
because it's almost like the FBI was
telling the the Obama doj this is one
guy you may want to go after because
he's one of our political opponents
that's really what DeSantis was all
about so I think you're right I think
for DeSantis the question is this if he
if he wants to make this a kind of a
covid run
then he has a window of opportunity but
I think what DeSantis is doing and what
he's showing people and the reason
people really like him is that while
most Republicans come in and they sit on
their hands for two years or four years
and they do nothing they just make some
symbolic statements the sentence is like
if it's Monday we need an election Fraud
Unit and if it's Tuesday we need to go
after affirmative action and then on
Wednesday we're going to start up on
this and so this guy like never stops
that's right right that's what people
are looking for by the way both of them
are like that they're both like that
yeah both so that's what will Propel
DeSantis so if DeSantis is going to run
he shouldn't think of himself as a covet
candidate but he should think of himself
as let me identify the real nonsense
going on in this country and become the
guy that's not afraid to take all that
on in rhetoric and then in policy let me
ask the other question can you ever see
Reagan uh or Trump being a VP
believe it or not I can see it more with
Reagan than with Trump with Trump it's
harder to see because of Just The Way
Trump is I mean Trump is the other thing
is when you see Trump he's a little
different you know I've had a chance I
didn't know Trump by the way when people
say oh give you a pardon and so on when
Trump gave me a pardon I'd never met the
guy
um so so it wasn't like he was doing me
a favor or he owed me or anything like
that but since then I've gotten to know
him a little better and he's he's a very
interesting fellow but he also is like
he marches to his own drummer and and
Reagan did not do that Reagan in in the
end was in fact a party man uh in fact
Reagan has famous statements where he
says things like never criticize your
own party you know that's the 11th
commandment of being a republican so
with Reagan let's just say in a freak
case had had Gerald Ford offered him the
vice president I think Reagan would have
taken it so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]